it's morning Oh  not blowing is what you're looking very  nice today tada  can you believe people we're gonna throw  this stuff out fools this is absolutely  amazing check out the phone hello  hey Jake collabs you must work out often  nah I don't  mm Jesus Ted find her  who's that a new dating app what do we  have here  I don't know it's good here whoa let me  ask you a question how much will this  get me you have a second what do you  think let me take a look at you okay  there's a few top and the suit bottom  actually matched or did you mix and  match him they come as a set you look  ready for your first day of work thank  you  come on it's not you machine never lark  you know it's cool I'm just I'm just  gonna go hit up the ATM hey let me get  20 bucks let me see if my dad put some  money in my house